Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and next week
Doctor Who Series 8 premieres.
Congrats to anyone who’s made it to the
World Tour so far, some of you have been sending
me really awesome pics on twitter and facebook.
The next stop as of the day I’m posting
this is New York.
I live in Los Angeles so I won’t be able
to get arrested trying to tackle Peter Capaldi
with hugs but if one of you guys wants to
try tweet the pictures before you get handcuffed.
They just released a proper trailer for Episode
1 Deep Breath so this video will be a breakdown
of the new things in that and we’ve also
learned the titles from all of the regular
episodes.
There are 12.
The 13th is the christmas special but we don’t
know anything about that yet.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I do Doctor Who video every week.
And I’m doing a weekly Doctor Who giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Details in the description too.
So let’s start with the Deep Breath Trailer.
A lot of it is familiar footage and because
it jumps around in the episode I’m going
to reorganize things from the same scenes
as I go along.
Here we go:
Starting with Dinosaur’s in London.
I know some of you weren’t really taken
with Dinosaurs on a Spaceship but as much
as the T-Rex is comedy.
It’s sheer size makes you think less of
Trikey and more of Jurassic Park.
Fun Fact: Gallifrey, Mondas and Skaro all
used to have their own species of Dinosaurs.
The Gallifreyan ones were called Gigantosaurs.
They only appeared in the comics.
The Skaro ones were just triceratops with
one big horn and the Mondas ones were pretty
much like the earth dinosaurs since Mondas
was Earth’s twin planet.
The Mondas cybermen even converted some of
the dinosaurs into cybermen to use as mounts.
I don’t think this dinosaur is connected
to any of the villains this season, I think
it’s just there to introduce Capaldi with
some flair, but the Doctor does speak Dinosaur
and I’m not talking about Silurian, Vastra’s
native language.
He can speak to big dinosaurs like the T-Rex.
I don’t know if they’ll actually show
this but I think it’s kind of funny.
Here’s the Doctor out of Matt Smith’s
costume but not yet in his new one, this episode
is the transition from Smith to Capaldi, so
naturally he has to get into his new outfit.
But the promo pics we’ve seen and the other
trailer footage show him wearing a victorian
outfit that’s different from what his Doctor
Costume will be.
This is what the official costume is, presumably
he’ll be in it by the end of the first episode.
Smith changed his appearance a few times during
the Christmas Special.
The way I see it is you have the anachronistic
Matt Smith costume.
Young man in very old timey clothes and now
we’re actually way back in Victorian era
when those clothes would have been totally
normal.
Cut to old man appropriately dressed in old
man’s clothes.
All of the interview quotes I’ve been seeing
from the World Tour have been about how no-nonsense
Capaldi is going to be.
Most of the interviews sound like they’re
meant for people who have never read doctor
who, because I feel like anyone who watched
the 50th Anniversary and saw that clip of
his eyes, knew exactly what his personality
was going to be.
You can let me know if you agree, but I just
thought he was going to be a badass.
The next montage sets up the action of the
episode, them dealing with the Dinosaur, the
mysterious Robot Man and the fact the Doctor
is still delirious from his regeneration.
What the Doctor says in case you have trouble
understanding him when he talks really fast
in his scottish accent is “The Question
is, Have there been any similar Murders?”.
There was a rumor that Jack the Ripper would
be involved in the episode and I haven’t
seen any evidence that he is.
But the rumors might have been referring to
the robot man.
Vastra said she killed and ate Jack the Ripper
during Good Man Goes to War, series 6 episode
7.
So I’m pretty sure it’s not him that made
that big explosion.
I like that Vastra implies that no matter
how addled the Doctor’s mind is from regeneration,
he automatically hones in on trouble.
It looks like we’ll get another badass Vastra
and Jenny battle.
They got a pretty good one during Crimson
Horror too.
That was series 7 episode 12.
I like that they gave Clara the Doctor’s
“You’ve redecorated line”.
Most people probably remember this from the
50th last year, but the second doctor originated
it.
The first time he said it was during the three
doctor’s special when he saw the third doctor’s
tardis, then again in the five doctors special
inside the UNIT headquarters to Brigadier
Lethbridge-Stewart, then Matt Smith said it
to Craig when he saw his house in Closing
Time Series 6 Episode 12 and then most recently
David Tennant said it to Matt Smith when he
saw his TARDIS.
Clara is referencing the Book Shelves mostly.
I think Matt Smith did have bookshelves and
paintings inside the control room after he
redecorated before he met Clara in the 2012
christmas special.
There were also bookshelves inside the seventh
doctor’s TARDIS.
It was more victorian looking.
I think it’s a nice easter egg since Capaldi’s
first episode is during the victorian era.
I guess we’ll find out if the bookshelves
stick.
I think the footage we saw of them in the
previous trailers was from the first few episodes.
I can’t wait to get a better look inside.
Structurally though it’s the same as Matt
Smith’s final TARDIS, just new decorations.
I think that Capaldi’s smile is just him
acknowledging the humor of her taking what
should be his line.
And now on to episode titles I’m just going
to present all these as a montage with text
instead of reading them out loud.
Here we go:
So remember, Episode 1 airs Saturday the 23rd.
If you’re watching it on BBC One I think
it’s 7 or 8PM GMT.
But if you have access to BBC America they’re
also premiering John Simm’s new series Intruders
right after Doctor Who.
It’s going to be like Orphan Black season
1, where they air Doctor Who first and Intruders
right after for the entire season.
I’m not planning on doing any videos for
Intruders but I will be watching.
This week because the official Doctor Who
team at the BBC requested it I’m doing a
video for good Classic Who episodes to watch
before series 8.
It’s okay, even if you never watched classic
who or the new series, Episode 1 of Series
8 is designed to explain all the basics anyway,
so don’t feel weird about jumping on if
you’re totally new.
And I’ll be doing a ton of videos every
week.
It’s going to be a lot of fun.
What I’m going to do is before each episode
I’m going to post a bonus video about a
specific villain or a story I think is interesting
to the current episode, then I’ll post my
regular episode review and then a Q&A.
The giveaways will always start in the episode
review videos just like I did for game of
thrones and I’ll name winners in the Q&As.
I am posting a Q&A for this video tonight
so if you want to enter the giveaway, just
make sure to subscriber and leave a comment.
There’s only one winner per video.
Right now click here for the Q&A, i’ll add
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here to learn about Peter Capaldi coming back
for series 9.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight!